after the first two episodes of
wandavision dropped on disney plus
fans of the marvel cinematic universe
immediately set to work
picking apart every little detail of the
classic tv-inspired pseudo-sitcom
there are lots of people places and even
objects that potentially hint at how
wanda vision could change marvel's tv
universe going forward
take westview community leader dottie
dottie like many of the residents of
west view
is already beginning to see through the
cracks in wanda vision's world
as she and wanda clean up after a town
planning event
she makes it clear that she has heard
things about wanda and vision
and moreover doesn't trust them more
than that
when a mysterious voice calling wanda's
name is heard coming through the static
of a nearby radio
both wanda and dottie are able to hear
it
it's obvious that there's more to
westview and dottie than meets the eye
and the actor who plays her likely seems
more than a bit familiar
nothing like what you two just did up
here has
ever happened in the history of our
talent show
her name is emma caulfield ford and this
is far from her first foray into the
world of science fiction and
fantasy perhaps you've seen her in fear
the walking dead
supergirl once upon a time or another of
her dozens of tv appearances
over the years but chances are you know
her from buffy the vampire slayer
in season three of buffy cordelia chase
wishes that buffy summers had never come
to sunnydale
thus creating an alternate universe
ruled by the master
and overrun by his creatures of the
night in one of the most iconic episodes
of the show the scary veiny good fairy
who made cordy's wish come true
why that would be none other than emma
caulfield ford
known at the time as just emma caulfield
as the vengeance demon
anya it wouldn't be until the fourth
season of buffy that anya would be
slotted in as a series regular but it
didn't take long before fans realized
the character would become far more than
cordelia's replacement
after she absconded to los angeles with
angel anya was a fresh
snarky take on the inhuman being must
learn to be human
trope after centuries of helping scorned
women take extreme revenge
on the men who spurned them anya becomes
friends with buffy and the gang
while also falling in love with sandra
harris the romance between anya
and xander is a huge part of the buffy
story and
very nearly leads to marriage of course
it wouldn't be buffy
if true love didn't lead to misery so we
get to see anya cope with being a
vengeance demon
all over again making her one of the
most complex characters
in buffy's seven season history the same
year that buffy the vampire slayer
concluded its seven season run
emma caulfield ford was already starring
in a horror movie with a concept that
actually feels like it could have come
straight out of an episode of buffy
darkness falls darkness falls is both
the name of the 2003 film
and the town in which the story is set
raising the question
who would choose to live in a town named
darkness falls
the answer as you might have guessed is
emma caulfield ford
playing caitlyn greene in a nightmare on
elm street
wes craven found success redefining the
sandman as
a knife-fingered monster who kills you
in your dreams
named freddy krueger darkness falls
performs a similar trick
but this time it's the tooth fairy
getting a murderous makeover
just like the parents from elm street
killed kruger the parents of darkness
falls kill matilda dixon
aka the tooth fairy the difference is
that matilda dixon was innocent of the
crimes she was accused of
the result is the same the tooth fairy
becomes a vengeful spirit
and returns to do some killing
considering caulfield ford
just wrapped playing a vengeance demon
on buffy she naturally was the perfect
person to fight an
evil tooth fairy two years before black
mirror existed in any form
emma caulfield ford starred as una
o'leary in 2009's timer
a movie with a very similar premise to
the black mirror episode
hang the dj in the future most people
accept who their soulmate will be
via a high-tech dating app the app in
timer is a device installed in the wrist
that counts down to when a person will
meet their soulmate
but una's clock is not counting down
does she have no soulmate
is her soulmate dead or has her soulmate
simply not gotten their own device
installed timer is a classic science
fiction exploration of free will vs
destiny
set through the lens of a romantic
comedy plus
there are two interesting things about
timer as it pertains to wanda vision
the first is that there seems to be a
question of whether or not the residents
of west view are there of their own free
will
or not even more interesting however is
that
jack shafer who wrote and directed timer
is also the showrunner for wandavision
so if there's any role from caulfield
ford's past that's relevant to
wandavision
it's definitely oona from timer
now you can clap
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about the mcu
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one